[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à strasbourg pour une nouvelle émission
d'europe hebdo émission spéciale
direction le royaume uni l'homme de la
semaine c'est lui victoire historique
pour boris johnson qui obtient une très
large majorité à la chambre des communes
la plus large depuis margaret thatcher
en 1987
conséquence le pays va bel et bien
quitter l'union européenne le 31 janvier
dans un peu plus d'un mois
comment expliquer cette victoire de
boris johnson quel avenir pour le
royaume uni en dehors de l'union
européenne 1 doit-on craindre un nouveau
concurrent aux portes de l'europe
le thème d' europe hebdo cette semaine
braxis dernière ligne droite
bon joint sur ce plateau deux invités
christian allard bonjour vous êtes
député européen britannique élu sur la
liste du parti indépendantiste écossais
à vous siégez ou des verts ici au
parlement repères après le référendum
sur le break suite à votre camp est
devenu le premier défenseur de l'union
européenne large victoire aux
législatives britanniques avec 48 sièges
sur 59 remporté parti nationaliste
écossais a aussitôt relancé le débat sur
l'indépendance merci d'être venu
stéphane séjourné bonjour vous êtes
député européen chef de file des macros
nistos parlement européen eurodéputés du
groupe renault en europe à renouveler
l'europe merci d'être venu alors à peine
réélu à une écrasante majorité boris
johnson met la pression sur bruxelles a
pour parvenir à un accord commercial
post break site avant la fin 2020
excluant toute prolongation de la
période de transition censée adoucir la
sortie du royaume uni de l'union
européenne ont fait un point sur le
résultat de ces élections et on réagit
juste après
[Musique]
il n'a pas perdu de temps 48 heures
après les élections législatives
il est venu dans le nord-est de
l'angleterre fief du parti travailliste
boris johnson exulte ce bastion de la
gauche a voté pour lui
le premier ministre conservateur et pour
cause son slogan de campagne était
simple get debré accident ne faisons le
bric site
[Applaudissements]
on va faire des choses fantastiques
notre pays s'est lancé dans une
merveilleuse aventure et nous allons
retrouver notre confiance en nous mêmes
notre mojo notre confiance en nous et
nous allons faire les choses
différemment et mieux en tant que pays
plus rien désormais ne se pose donc
ombre excite tant désirée par le premier
ministre en remportant 3 165 sièges à la
chambre des communes
boris johnson obtient la majorité
absolue les travaillistes de jeremy
corbyn arrive en seconde position avec 2
103 sièges seulement le les bourses
s'effondrent pire score depuis 1935
suivent les nationalistes écossais et
les libéraux-démocrates adoubé boris
johnson promet la sortie de l'union
européenne au 31 janvier prochain après
ratification de l'accord au parlement
enfin qui à sa cause les travaillistes
des familles pourront rien leur leader
jérémie corps been annonce qu'il ne
conduirait pas le parti pour les
prochaines élections
le brésil a tellement polarisé divise et
le débat dans ce pays qu'il a pris le
dessus sur le débat politique normal je
reconnais que cela contribue au résultat
que le parti travailliste a obtenu
partout dans le pays
enfin il faut noter le très bon score
des nationalistes écossais pro européen
de quoi renforcer leur volonté d'obtenir
un nouveau référendum sur l'indépendance
de l'écossé et accepte le greffe mai
j'accepte malheureusement que boris
johnson est un mandat pour réaliser le
break site en angleterre mais il n'a pas
de mandat
en aucun cas pour sortir les cosses de
l'union européenne s'il va dans cette
direction il balayera le principe même
du royaume uni l'idée que l'union est un
partenariat de nations et gaz dans les
rues de londres
beaucoup voient dans ce vote la fin de
quatre années dans big 8 et je pense que
la majorité du royaume uni souhaitent
probablement que ce mandat politique
soit délivrée pour quitter l'union
européenne je suis ravie je pense que
boris a le mandat qu'il faut pour
réaliser le bric dit maintenant c'est
tout ce qu'il doit faire
après sa victoire le premier ministre
boris johnson mais son équipe en ordre
de bataille en vue de commencer dès
cette semaine à lever les obstacles au
break site une fois le break 6 de
réaliser sur le plan politique au 31
janvier londres et bruxelles entameront
d'âpres négociations pour parvenir à un
accord commercial définissant leurs
relations
à l'issue d'une période de transition
prévue jusqu'à fin 2020
[Musique]
alors question alors est ce que c'est
une victoire de boris johnson à qui
avait pour slogan pendant sa campagne
get de breaking dawn
faisons le breakbeat voulait en finir
c'est ça c'était un slogan très très
simple c'est évident mais plus qu'une
victoire de ben johnson il a seulement
un pour cent de plus qu'il avait aux
dernières élections
c'est surtout l'effondrement du parti
travailliste et c'est et c'est surtout
ça ce qui s'est passé et il y à il y
aquelques quelques jours c'est
l'effondrement du parti travailliste en
angleterre qui a bénéficié boris johnson
et en écosse comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même qui a bénéficié notre parti
nous sommes passés de 35 sièges à 47
sièges +1 48
donc nous avons maintenant l'autre
mandat pour avoir un référendum pour
l'indépendance pour l'année prochaine
que faire de ses journées victoire
personnelle de barry johnson ou des
fêtes déroute du parti travailliste
c'est une clarification très clair en
réalité il y avait un débat entre
potentiellement un référendum après
cette élection et on voit bien tout ce
débat sur le référendum n'a pu n'a plus
lieu d'être
donc évidemment une clarification sur la
sortie du royaume uni et je rejoins en
tout cas christian christian allard là
dessus en réalité c'est une défaite des
travaillistes et du lait beurre et donc
on se retrouve dans une situation
politique en tout cas qui est une
recomposition de la vie politique
britannique
comme on en avait eu vue et commandant
la vue en italie en france aussi une
forme de recomposition avec ben ceux qui
ont un mot d'ordre clair et une position
claire qui l'emportent et la briche
essonne a eu une position claire et
l'impression que le clivage
gauche-droite a été balayé un remplacé
par un clivage pro ou anti break site
lors de cet oui oui en quelque sorte ça
a été ça a été pour bruce johnson son
référendum
d'ailleurs il l'a voulu comme ça il a
remplacé cette élection législative par
par un vrai référendum qui posera
d'ailleurs d'autres questions c'est à
dire que derrière la question du brics
il ya aussi le maintien des politiques
publiques quelle est l'orientation
politique de ce gouvernement
on en parlera sûrement est ce qu'à un
gouvernement ultra-libéral qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent faire quel est le projet
politique pour pour le royaume uni
derrière la sortie du bourg excite et ça
c'est des questions aujourd'hui que on
peut se poser et qui nous inquiète aussi
puisque derrière cette élection bien il
n'y a pas de grand chose à part le brix
une christian allard le très bon score
des nationalistes et que c'est ce qu'on
va avoir un nouveau référendum sur
l'indépendance de l'écossé pour rester
dans l'union européenne
les écossais pour être tourné le dos au
royaume uni s'est pas vraiment tourné le
dos et est resté au sein de l'union
européenne qui nous est très cher
n'oublions pas qu'en 2016 le référendum
pour l'upa exit les écossais ont voté à
plus de 60 2% pour rester de l'union
européenne donc nous nous sentons au
coeur de l'union européenne et nous nous
voulons absolument rester dans l'union
européenne c'est pour ça que nous avons
décidé d'avoir un référendum si la
grande-bretagne sortait de l'union
européenne avant de savoir si boris
johnson serait promue ministre ou pas ça
ça nous l'avons décidé il y a longtemps
même avant avant le référendum nous
avons devancé un petit peu les
événements donc bien sûr maintenant en
voyant boris johnson qu'il a comme on
l'a entendu qui n'a aucune politique
il a un slogan c'est tout get back side
donne qui ne veut pas dire grand cho
nous avons une politique très forte une
politique européenne
nous respectons les valeurs européennes
qui sont les nôtres et nous aurons à
référendum
l année prochaine en 2020 pour rester
dans l'union européenne
dans quelles sont les prochaines étapes
du break site le 31 janvier on divorce
et après on voit en tout cas aux futures
relations
en tout cas le rêve de bon voisinage le
scénario est maintenant clair dire que
je pense que la grande bretagne décidera
du coût de la sortie de l'union
européenne le parlement européen aura à
s'exprimer sur cet accord d'ailleurs
avant le 31 janvier et on aura à voter
christian allard moi-même l'ensemble des
parlementaires ici à strasbourg auront à
voter sur cet accord éventuel de
séparation en espérant qu'il en est un
et qu'il n'y ait pas de rebondissements
entre temps et puis derrière il y aura
une période de transition et cette
période de transition c'est tout le
débat qui aura entre la commission le
conseil le parlement et la grande
bretagne pour savoir quel est le bonne
transition
la france a des enjeux là dedans
notamment à la question de la pêche est
un enjeu dans cet élément de transition
puisqu'il faut encore qu'on arrive à
récupérer quelques éléments de
négociation dans cet accord éventuel
bilatérales entre la france et la grande
bretagne pour préserver les intérêts
aussi des pêcheurs français là dessus
c'est un enjeu pour la délégation que je
préside et puis il y aura d'autres
événements agression alors là dit
notamment en irlande et en écosse pour
éventuellement se redéfinir par rapport
à l'union européenne et ça c'est encore
des péripéties qui nous attendent dans
les deux trois prochaines années je
pense là il va y avoir donc une phase de
négociation d'association avec l'union
européenne est ce qu a pas un risque de
dumping social que le royaume uni soit
le moins disant
socialement moins disant fiscal mans et
qui concurrencent finalement l'union
européenne bien sûr c'est pour ça que
les codes veut rester dans l'union
européenne
parce que ce sont des valeurs
européennes qui nous qui nous sont très
très cher cette concurrence illégale que
qu'on voit vraiment avec donna trompe
l'ami de boris johnson ces deux là vont
faire en sorte de concurrence et
l'europe d'une façon tout à fait déloyal
et nous ne voulons pas en faire partie
une autre chose que je voulus des reçus
au sujet de boris johnson c'est que nous
et le 31 et l'échéance du 31 janvier
n'oublions pas que rien ne s'est passé
les trois dernières années les trois
dernières années et demie le
gouvernement conservateur de theresa may
avec boris johnson ont été complètement
incompétent et n'ont jamais réussi à
rentrer dans vraiment des négociations
il importe importante avec l'union
européenne
donc nous sommes seulement au
commencement du commencement et 26
journées à singapour sur tamise c'est
possible moyennant fiscale moi disant
film social en réalité ce que je disais
on ne connaît pas le projet politique
est effectivement et l'âge des
ultralibéraux les gens dans la city
certains ou commencé à soutenir le veau
excite pas ce qu'il y avait derrière ce
projet politique de faire un paradis
fiscal à quelques kilomètres des côtes
européennes
et derrière des intérêts économiques
majeures on pense toujours que le break
site c'est une volonté populaire des
classes populaires et c'est en réalité
le bris qu'il a commencé par des
intérêts économiques importants des gens
qui avaient beaucoup d'argent qui était
dans la city qui avait un projet
politique et donc ça il faut quand même
le rappeler est donc un risque il ya un
risque mais d'où l'importance de cet
accord avec la corde de séparation
quelque sorte de divorce qui doit
justement éviter ça et garder le lien
aussi avec l'union européenne
évidemment quand même d'avantagé chance
et fin 2020 bien sûr on peut pas avoir
donné un avantage et fin 2020 de toute
façon il faudra il faudra trancher et
nous on a intérêt à un accord christian
allard dernière question vous êtes
député européen le 31 janvier vous
quittez le parlement européen
non je ne quitterai pas lent corse
restera au coeur de l'europe c'est
important et pourtant si le quitter oui
mais pourquoi pas que lesdites juridique
vous vous êtes là où 31 janvier ou pas
mais les deux se seraient les députés
écossais et les députés d'irlande du
nord pourrait peut-être rester au
parlement en tant qu observateur
peut-être en pensant que nous
reviendrons dans l'europe en fin de 2020
avant que la période de transition c'est
terminé affaire à suivre
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors on le sait à la personnalité de
boris johnson a joué dans cette victoire
aux législatives à l'homme jours à
l'homme du peuple un mec sympa limite
clownesque parfois et ça paye portrait
avec thomas des prêts
[Musique]
la victoire de boris johnson est à
l'image de sa campagne éclair comme un
bulldozer
il a tout renversé tantôt poissonnier
gardien de foot conducteurs de bus et
même livreur de lait le premier ministre
a multiplié les coups de com et les
mises en scènes loufoques
[Musique]
avec un seul mot d'ordre bien près de 7
tonnes
résultat des courses ça a marché
le leader du parti conservateur réalise
le meilleur score de son camp depuis
margaret thatcher avec une majorité
écrasante de 364 sièges
c'est l'humiliation pour le parti
travailliste mais pour le député jean
louis bourlanges vice président de la
commission des affaires européennes
ce n'est pas une grande surprise tout le
monde était en réalité désireux qu'il
ait une majorité même si on n'est pas
d'accord avec lui si j'osais une formule
je dirais que même bruxelles a voté
johnson alors que recèlent bien entendu
était a priori hostile aubrac sites
comme le veut la tradition boris johnson
a été reçu à la mi-journée par la reine
pour être reconduit dans ses fonctions
charge à lui désormais de mettre en
oeuvre le brésil prévue pour le 31
janvier
[Musique]
alors mon choix pour cette deuxième
partie deux eurodéputés françois-xavier
bellamy bonjour je vous êtes ce député
européen du groupe l'est républicain
membre du groupe ppe ici au parlement
européen merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation à côté de vous fabienne
keller
bonjour vous êtes députée européenne du
groupe renouvelé l'europe a le groupe de
la majorité présidentielle un peu chez
vous ici à vous avez été longtemps maire
de strasbourg merci d'être venu alors on
vient de voir ce sujet on la
sous-estimer boris johnson
françois-xavier bellamy on m'a
certainement sous-estimé la volonté des
britanniques de mettre fin à ce
feuilleton interminable qui pèse sur la
vie politique britannique bien plus
encore que sur la vie de chacun de nos
pays ou même de l'union européenne pour
les britanniques aujourd'hui j'ai été en
grande bretagne à londres il ya quelques
semaines il est très clair que le bric
site est devenu un sujet universel
uniforme depuis trop longtemps et qu'il
est temps pour eux de se consacrer à
autre chose il est temps aussi pour nous
de pouvoir construire notre partenariat
futur c'est la chose qui compte le plus
et donc ce vote il est comme le disait
jean louis bourlanges dans votre
reportage à l'instant le signe d'une
forme d'exaspération qui s'est concentré
aujourd'hui vers la volonté de mettre
fin à ce feuilleton galère ça y est
c'est à qui il ya une rupture le royaume
uni quitté l'union européenne c'est un
grand pays qui par quelles conséquences
pour pour les découpes des conséquences
concrètes à pour les britanniques dans
l'union européenne et pour les européens
au royaume uni c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle pour l'europe c'est la première
fois historiquement depuis le rêve des
pères fondateurs
l'europe elle n'a cessé de s'agrandir
que c'était l'aspiration de tous les
pays européens dès qu'il se libérer du
joug soviétique ou d'une dictature
ils rejoignent l union c'était
l'espérance d'une vie commune meilleur
hélas un pays sort alors bon on savait
qu'ils avaient une relation compliquée
c'est une île il avait tardé à rentrer
dans l'union mais quand même c'est un
grand partenaire en termes économiques
qui a beaucoup de britanniques en europe
et d'européens au royaume uni
il y avait des liens très important
c'est le seul pays qui a résisté aux
nazis pendant la guerre ils nous ont
accueillis ils ont accueilli de gueule
en 39 donc voilà c'est un grand pays ami
il faudra construire la relation futurs
en gardant ce liens historiques forts
mais dans de nouvelles circonstances
c'est tout l'enjeu de l'année des onze
mois de négociations entre le 31 janvier
et fin décembre
il faut rajouter quelque chose quand
même si boris johnson à une telle
majorité
c'est grâce à nigel farage ce monsieur
qui pendant vingt ans à hurler contre
l'europe
il ne s'est pas présentée dans toutes
les circonscriptions où il y avait un
candidat conservateur
il a drôlement aider il y avait une
sorte d'union des droites dures il a
drôlement aider boris johnson à faire ce
score exceptionnel
alors les dirigeants européens sont déjà
dans l'étape d'après sont inquiets on
écoute les réactions du président macro
et de la chancelière allemande angela
merkel
ribérac semaine contre aliens en fait il
y aura désormais à notre porte un
concurrent un pays qui n'est plus membre
du marché unique et bien sûr ce
concurrent devra largement réfléchir à
la manière dont il va modifier scénario
est donc la chancelière a raison de dire
que en même temps qu'il était un ami un
partenaire c'est de çà devient un
concurrent parce qu'il est hors de
l'union mais on ne veut pas que ce soit
un concurrent déloyal
[Musique]
alors il ya l'étape d'après négociations
d'associations accord commercial est ce
qu'on risque pas de voir surgir un
singapour sur tamise un royaume uni
moins disant social moins disant fiscal
un concurrent déloyal aux portes de
l'europe
françois-xavier bellamy il faut
construire se partagent ce partenariat
futur et fabienne keller le disais à
l'instant il ya un lien entre nos pays
qui est évident par l'histoire par la
culture mais aussi tout simplement par
la géographie l'économie mais les
questions de défense et évidemment nous
lie aussi bien sûr il est évident que ce
partenariat doit être construit mais ce
sera difficile parce que la plupart des
accords que nous avons construit avec
d'autres régions du monde se faisait
dans un contexte de convergence
on se rapprochait les uns des autres et
le contraire jean st moment de
divergence
il faut qu'on soit effectivement et je
crois que c'est ce qui a été menée ici
notamment par michel barnier au cours
des dernières années
il faut qu'on soit capable de travailler
de façon constructive avec le royaume
uni
mais il faut également que nous
assumions de défendre les intérêts de
nos pays avec ce partenaire notamment je
pense au plan commercial au plan
économique nous avons beaucoup à
construire ensemble je suis ici par
exemple le notamment de la commission de
la pêche sur la question de pêche la
question de la gestion de ressources
maritimes ya évidemment un travail
décisif à faire avec la grande bretagne
mais il faut que dans ce travail en
assument de défendre ceux qui en france
ceux qui en europe ont besoin de pouvoir
voir garanti leur propre intérêt leurs
propres besoins dans ce dialogue qui
s'engage
fabienne keller est ce qu'on n'a pas un
risque le royaume uni bascule du côté
des états unis on a vu les les appels de
donald trump
alors les banques commerciales les
britanniques c'est un peuple très
pragmatique
donc voilà de nombreux liens ont été
tissés en 45 ans de participation à
l'union européenne
ils vont continuer à faire vivre
certains liens dans d'autres cas ils
vont essayer de tirer avantage de cette
nouvelle situation
c'est tout l'enjeu de la négociation
effectivement que conduit michel barnier
pour trouver une nouvelle relation
équilibrée mais moi sur ce planche pas
trop inquiète parce que je pense que de
part et d'autre on a intérêt à
construire un accord voilà qui respecte
chacun et qui a un phare gray man comme
on dit en alsace hier un accord
équilibré
vous parlez des dons conséquents ont
parlé des conséquences a des
conséquences concrètes en oeuvre écrite
par exemple parce qu'il ya eu un moment
de panique quand on s'est dit qu'il y
aurait peut-être un arbre excite c'est à
dire une sortie non négocier sur la
question des médicaments et on s'est
rendu compte qu'il y avait des
médicaments produits en europe
continentale indispensable royaume uni
et réciproquement des médicaments
britannique dont avait besoin certains
patients européens
donc je forme le voeu qu'on trouve les
voies pour un accord apaisé et peut-être
même
faudra-t-il se donner un peu plus de
temps puisque aujourd'hui l'échéance
pour tous les nouveaux accords
intermédiaires et de long terme c'est le
31 décembre 2020 ça fera que onze mois
de discussions alors qu'a effectivement
beaucoup beaucoup de dossiers et
beaucoup aussi de nouvelles conventions
à établir puisque le royaume uni
deviendra un état tiers un état tiers a
donc à défaut d'accord commercial les
relations économiques entre bruxelles et
londres serait réglée par les règles de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
deux lots de lait de l'om c'est vous
pensez que c'est possible
françois-xavier bellamy on n'a pas
d'autre solution que de construire un
partenariat c'est plus dur à 6 des
droits de douane pour la circulation des
marchandises
prenons prenons prenons quelques
exemples simples les filières
industrielles sont très intégrés
dans les régions qui sont proches de la
grande bretagne je pense par exemple à
la région de france il ya évidemment une
proximité avec la grande bretagne qui
fait que beaucoup de produits sont
fabriqués en faisant des allers retours
entre nos pays si à chaque fois il
devait y avoir effectivement imposition
de droits de douane ça crée des
frictions des frottements ça crée aussi
des coûts qui seront évidemment très
défavorable il faut construire un
partenariat avec ce pays je crois
qu'effectivement la grande bretagne est
marqué par son pragmatisme vous le
disiez à l'instant je pense qu'encore
une fois la question fondamentale c'est
est ce que nous assumerons de de
défendre des intérêts qui sont
fondamentaux pour nous prenons encore
une fois la question de delà de la
gestion de la ressource maritime
il est très clair que ça a été on l'a
peut-être trop peu suivie en france mais
un enjeu majeur du débat interne à la
grande bretagne sur le sur le break site
parce que le fait de devoir respecter la
politique commune des pêches en europe
les quotas de pêche le fait de voir
entrer dans leurs eaux territoriales des
pêcheurs venus de toute l'europe était
pour les britanniques
une forme de 2,2 de poids dont il
voulait se défaire nous nous devons dire
aujourd'hui 50% de la pêche française
est réalisé dans les eaux britanniques
que si les britanniques veulent un
accord de libre échange avec nous eh
bien il faut par exemple mettre ce point
là en priorité dans les négociations
pour faire en sorte qu effectivement ce
sujet là sur lequel nous sommes
aujourd'hui fragile nous puissions le
défendre résolument dans lé cadre des
discussions qui vont s'ouvrir
donc je crois qu'il faut évidemment
n'avoir aucune espèce de fermeture mais
il faut n'avoir aucune naïveté non plus
le 31 janvier donc le royaume uni quitté
l'union
on sera plus que 27 est ce que ça peut
donner des idées à d'autres pays sur le
thème à ils sont partis on peut partir
de aussi c'est ben ça alors oui c'est
bientôt la suède
c'est bien pour cela que la sortie du
royaume uni de l'union m'inquiète
profondément parce qu'on trouvera des
commentateurs politiques des mouvements
politiques pour nous expliquer que c'est
beaucoup mieux à l'extérieur donc ils
trouveront des relais dans l'europe des
et donc cela attisera d'autres envies à
l'occasion peut-être d'une crise
d'un problème dans un secteur
particulier dans des états membres au
dans les 27 états membres
cette idée pourrait être relayée donc on
va perdre beaucoup d'énergie alors que
le principe de l'union européenne c'est
que plus le temps passe plus on
progresse plus on s'intègre et la
prospérité commune qui est un bien
commun qui est liée à la libre
circulation aux normes partagées permet
de mieux redistribuer d'essayer
d'accompagner les plus fragiles
d'améliorer nos systèmes éducatifs et de
santé
donc c'est ce projet de porter ensemble
une vision commune se libérer de
contraintes et avoir un espace de
sécurité prospérité qui pourrait être
fragilisé
à charge pour nous les vingt-sept de
montrer que cela est possible dans une
bonne intelligence mais réaliste c'est
vrai avec le royaume uni
françois xavier bellamy si on posait la
question britannique dans 10 ans 1
est ce que vous voudriez refaire partie
de l'union européenne est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils liraient oui qu'est-ce
qu'ils peuvent revenir ou c'est
irréversible
notre travail ce serait de faire en
sorte de construire une union européenne
à laquelle les britanniques va eu de
nouveau participer je crois que le bric
site n'est pas le problème
le problème c'est tout ce qui a causé le
break site et il faut que et c'est le
travail que nous avons à faire pendant
le mandat qui commence que nous
puissions relever tous les défis qui
sont devant nous pour faire en sorte que
demain plus personne ne se disent qu
effectivement on est mieux à l'extérieur
de l'union européenne qu'à l'intérieur
mais ça suppose de régler les problèmes
qui ont créé chez les britanniques le
sentiment que l'union européenne les
fragiliser au lieu de les renforcer
ça suppose de faire face de manière
efficace aux défis économiques et il est
très clair que la libre circulation est
un atout mais que en ayant été peut être
trop rapide est peut-être mal maîtrisée
elle a créé des déséquilibres majeurs
qui ont causé des tensions très vives
dans nos sociétés et c'est le cas aussi
en france mais c'est le cas aussi dans
beaucoup de pays récemment arrivés en
europe qui ont connu ces tensions ces
déséquilibres
il faut qu'on arrive à se renforcer face
au défi écologique il faut qu'on arrive
à se renforcer face au défi migratoire
ensemble qu'on donne le sentiment aux
citoyens de nos pays que l'europe les
rend plus puissant plus capable de
décider de leur destin que s'il en était
privée et ça d'une certaine manière
c'est le travail qu'on à faire je n'ai
jamais pensé pour ma part que on ferait
reculer la défiance simplement en la
critiquant
on ne fait reculer la défiance que quand
on donne aux citoyens l'occasion de
faire de nouveau confiance c'est à dire
quand on construit une europe qui fait
la preuve de son efficacité
et c'est le travail qui nous attend
fabienne keller faut que l'union
européenne se remette en question pour
éviter de nouveaux brésil alors le
disent sur l'analyse de ce qui explique
le break site je ne partage pas tout à
fait les éléments de fond en fait moi
j'ai beaucoup travaillé depuis cinq ans
au sénat pour analyser ce qui se passait
dans la société britannique
il y a eu beaucoup de désinformation
beaucoup de filles nudes beaucoup de
reproches attribué à l'europe alors
qu'elle n'y est pour rien
le premier sujet au moment de la
campagne en 2016 c'était le système de
santé britannique dont disaient ce
qu'ils étaient favorables à la sortie
les polonais qui viennent travailler au
royaume-uni déséquilibre l'économie
monsieur farage monsieur johnson ont
même promis que ce système seraient
rééquilibrés après la sortie il n'a pas
plus été il a été obligé de lui donner
devenu premier ministre une subvention
exceptionnelle pour que son ca promesses
soient réalisés mais pas du tout pour
les raisons expliquées donc une campagne
de désinformation beaucoup de fake news
une des premières campagnes où on voit
le clivage aussi monde rural ceux qui
subissent la mondialisation et c'est là
que sur cet argument je suis d'accord il
ya le sujet de la prospérité partagée
qui n'est pas qu'un sujet européen mais
quand même avec des fractures qui sont
assez proches de celles qu'on a vécu en
france avec les jets les jaunes entre
une population qui a le sentiment
qu'elle perd sa qualité de vie son accès
au travail un certain nombre de
protections
à charge pour nous de proposer une
europe qui protège une europe qui assure
sur la question tellement sensible est
tellement utilisée par les populistes de
la migration des règles qu'on applique
avec humanité mais avec fermeté avec des
moyens européens donc que ça nous fasse
réfléchir oui mais l'europe
malheureusement on lui attribue souvent
des défauts qu'elle n'a pas mais elle ne
répond pas trop parce qu'elle n'est pas
autant porter un carnet à charge pour
nous députés européens celle appliquée
mieux l'europe c'est là où rejoignez
merci à vous d'être venu
débattre avec nous c'est la fin d'europe
m dos merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
passer de bonnes fêtes à est resté avec
nous sur les chaînes parlementaires et
la rtbf bail
[Musique]
les invités de bonjour chez vous demain
dès 7h30 la question de l'islam et du
voile déchaîne une nouvelle fois les
passions sur les réseaux sociaux médias
toujours en pointe sur les sujets cliver
et les thèmes polémiques avec des
stratégies de communication et parfois
des maladresses
avec quelles conséquences hashtag
amenez-le enquête hashtag demain à 23
heures sur public sénat bonjour chez
vous c'est votre émission nous vous
donnons la parole pour poser vos
questions à nos invités politiques vous
pouvez le faire via nos réseaux sociaux
ou dit à notre adresse bonjour chez vous
@ publicsenat.fr
et vos questions je les poserait en
direct à l'invité politique
vous avez la parole vous attend